[Music]
Hannah thank you very much thank you all
for coming what a fantastic crowd I'm so
glad to see so many people here I hope
for what will be a wonderful evening
which will leave you both enriched and
enthused we're here too we're here to
hear some letters being read out letters
that change the world letters in this
book written in history put together by
Simon seabag Montefiore it's a perfect
companion a book which you can just dip
into at random and get a sense of
something as as seabag says in the
introduction something that is both
authentic and at the same time something
that is captures just a moment there's
something so wonderful about reading
something that has just been caught in
in in that moment the immediacy of it
whether it's something that was from
thousands of years ago or even just a
few years ago who of us here doesn't
like receiving letters I feel
particularly sad but it appears to be
largely a habit that we've lost but
perhaps a bag will correct me and say
that it's coming back back into fashion
one of the things that he says he quotes
cursor in the introduction and I love
what he said about letters that they are
the most significant memorial a person
can leave that they represent the
immediate breath of life which is really
rather beautiful I'm delighted that we
have some fantastic speakers here with
us I'm going to introduce C bag first
Simon C bag Montefiore a prize-winning
historian and novelist whose
best-selling books have been published
in more than 48 languages his book
Catherine the Great and Potemkin was
shortlisted for the Samuel Johnson prize
and is being developed as a feature film
by Angelina Jolie Stalin the court of
the Reds are won the British Book Awards
in history and his latest book written
in history which I just held up letters
that changed the world
Kate Mosse to my left international
best-selling author known for her
multi-million selling longer dock tip
trilogy labyrinth Sepulchre and Citadel
her latest number-one best-selling novel
is the burning chambers it's the first
in an epic historical adventure series
and it's out in paperback next week she
is also the founder director of the
women's prize for fiction and only until
last week was the Deputy Chair of the
Royal National Theatre and the actors on
the stage delighted to welcome you all
right at the very end we're going to
start at the other end is Jade Anika
award-winning actor who has starred in
the Donmar Warehouse Shakespeare trilogy
she played Queen Margaret in the play of
that name last year at the Royal
Exchange and starred in the ITV drama
cleaning up alongside Sheridan Smith
Jack Loudon sitting next to her Scottish
actor who starred as an RAF fighter
pilot in the film Dunkirk and most
recently played Lord Darnley in the film
Mary Queen of Scots and he also appeared
in the BBC's production of war and peace
and next to him is Tamsin Greig
award-winning actor widely acclaimed for
her stage performances perhaps most
notably playing the role of Malvolio in
the National Theatre 20 2017 production
of Twelfth Night her television roles
include Green Wing and episodes and on
film she starred in Tamara Drewe and the
second Best Exotic Marigold Hotel and
next to her is Kwame quake armour
artistic director of the Young Vic
Theatre also an actor playwright singer
broadcaster his plays include of course
the award-winning El Nina's kitchen and
his series of eight 15-minute films soon
gone
a Windrush chronicle is currently being
shown on BBC Four I'm going to take a
breath so that you can give them a round
of applause
so we're going to just start by having a
little conversation with si bagging and
and Kate si bag as a historian just
outlined for us the importance of
lessers that give us a sense of what
they've meant to you and you've
discovered them in the writing of of
these books well and many of these are
many of the letters in this book are
well known but many of them are letters
I actually discovered in in the archives
myself and all my history books are
really based on original correspondence
and there is something incredibly
exciting in in finding a letter that no
one's seen before I remember some of
Stalin's letters you can actually smell
his pipe smoke on them still and so
letters are something with an immediacy
and an excitement that really that
really is is as Goethe said you know the
spark of life and he also said you know
to destroy a letter is to destroy a
piece of life itself and yet many
letters are destroyed so some of these
letters in the book I've actually seen
the originals of and some of the ones
were reading tonight and that's why that
that's why I letters are so exciting
they catch a moment they may not be true
before they may not be true afterwards
but the moment that someone puts pen to
paper that is truth that is the present
in its most essential form and that's
that's the wonderful thing about these
letters okay in writing historical
fiction to what extent is there the same
exhilaration when when you you know that
you'll may in fact be fictionalizing
nothing that you've discovered well yes
I mean I write imaginary friends against
the backdrop of real history but what
seabag says is absolutely right because
most of my novels are led by unheard
women and the ones that don't appear in
the history books actually it's through
letters and sometimes wills that you can
build up the texture of what a woman's
life would be so what would it mean to
live in France in the 16th century if
you're not a princess or a queen you
don't appear anywhere so when you're
trying to find those lost voices
particularly women's voices it is in the
letters when they say I leave this Bible
to my beloved daughter I leave this to
my beloved son I leave a pair of
and that actually often is letters is
what is the foundation of historical
fiction - so I grub around in the
archives as well you know and all you
ever want is to find that one thing that
will suddenly make your book take flight
that one woman's voice that would never
have been out there otherwise and it is
always in the letters that you find them
so I want I want to know from both of
you whether you have received a letter
that you treasure and that you might
want to share a little bit of story we
don't want to share but I certainly get
some pretty bizarre letters from readers
and cuz I wrote a book about the
Romanovs recently I received a letter
just about every week from someone who
claims to be one of the Romanovs the
other day I received a letter it was on
a letter from a reader that just said it
was just one line long and it just said
I know you know your history but do you
remember your history and I looked at
the name at the bottom and I gradually
realized it was the first girl I kissed
40 years ago so yeah that's young I'm
just just before we move on I'm just
going to share a little letter anecdote
I once wrote a letter to my tutor at
University to say that I couldn't finish
the essay because I was dead I think the
thing with the letters that you get sent
as an author is that sometimes it is
just so clear that the person has missed
the point so I was really pleased with a
beautiful description in in the burning
chambers of my new book of an owl taking
flight and all of that you know all of
this malarkey before the battle started
and I got this letter from someone
saying madam
and that's always bad side when it's our
madam your description you know I love
your books I think it's really great all
the rest of it but I would like to point
out that owls do not make any noise when
they fly and he enclosed a membership
form for the owl appreciation society
and I felt that was a result
I'm assuming you've kept all these
messes there's something wonderful about
that sieve Oh God can I ask you to
introduce the first letter that that
we're going to discuss and then here
read captain ad Chater to his mother
Christmas World War one well this is
from Christmas 1914
it's an extraordinary moment in history
it's an extraordinary human moment and
World War one as was supposed to be over
by Christmas and yet here they were at
Christmas and the war was still going on
but on Christmas Day something quite
extraordinary happened and it's
described in a letter and this is a
letter from a young captain in the
British Army
Tonkin Chater and and I think you'll
agree it's one of the most bizarre and
special moments in world war one before
the war really turned into the great
slaughterhouse that we recognized and
just to say captain che to have survived
and lived until the 1970s so this letter
is going to be read by Jack thanks jack
dearest mother I am writing this in the
trenches in my dugout with a wood fire
going and plenty of straw it is rather
cozy although it is freezing hard and
real Christmas weather I think I have
seen one of the most extraordinary
sights today that anyone has ever seen
about ten o'clock this morning I was
peeping over the parapet when I saw a
German waving his arms and presently two
of them got out of their trenches and
came toward those we were just going to
fire on them when we saw they had no
rifles so one of our men went out to
meet with them and in about two minutes
they'd grown between the two lines of
trenches were swarming with men and
officers of both sides shaking hands and
wishing each other a happy Christmas
this continued for about half an hour
when most of our men were ordered back
to the trenches for the rest of the day
nobody has fired a shot
and men have been wandering about at
well on the top of the parapet and
carrying straw and firewood about in the
open I went out myself and shook hands
with several of their officers and men
from what I gathered most of them would
be as glad to get home again as we
should we have had our pipes playing all
day and everyone has been wandering
about in the open unmolested but not of
course as far as the enemy lines the
troops will probably go on until someone
is foolish enough to let off his rifle
we nearly messed it up this afternoon by
one of our fellows letting off his rifle
skywards by mistake but they did not
seem to notice so it did not matter I am
writing this back in billets the same
business continues as yesterday and we
had another parley with the Germans in
the middle we exchanged cigarettes and
autographs and some more people took
photos we are at any rate having another
truce on New Year's Day as the Germans
want to see how the photos came out
it is really very extraordinary that
this sort of thing should happen in a
war in which there is so much bitterness
and ill feeling the Germans in the front
of the line are certainly sportsmen if
they are nothing else of course I don't
suppose it has happened everywhere along
the line although I do think that
indiscriminate fighting has more or less
stopped in most places on Christmas Day
your loving son Duggan
that's so poignant I just want to see
back how how many letters there were
about that incident and and what made
you choose that particular one I mean
maybe they weren't that many there
weren't that many there were a few there
was another incident further down the
line where they actually played football
between each other they kicked at the
Germans kicked the football and they had
a football game in the middle of the
trenches but the letters less-good and I
wanted to I wanted the most descriptive
letter of all of them and this is this
is the best of the letters and it's
quite nice because there are the letters
in the in the book where you say
afterwards unfortunately he was killed
three days later but the fact that he
survived to live a long life and have
children and grandchildren it makes this
a rather nice one to start with
lovely humor is wonderful and it's also
that the real poignancy of it that these
boys don't want to be doing that and the
boys on the other side don't want to be
doing that really and they therefore
kind of sorting it out and you know that
back in London and back in Berlin they
are keeping it going and that sort of
letter really brings that home I think I
mean it's beautiful letter and it is
lovely that you survived you're right
because it's very few teeth really the
next lesson we're going to hear was
written to Jessica Mitford by Rosa Parks
Kate will you introduce that letter for
us yes I mean like one of the reasons I
love the book and I love this letter is
that sometimes those most significant
moments of history turning are not clear
at the time we with hindsight know how
much this mattered but she didn't at the
time and so Rosa Parks you know wrote
this in 1956 and she was already a very
well-known activist and when she took on
the race laws in Alabama
you know the notorious Jim Crow laws and
sat on the back of that bus in December
1955 and she was arrested in 1955 and
her case was used of course and we know
the rest was history
but she's writing this letter to her
friend who is known as mrs. Troy haft
that was Jessica Mitford at the time was
married to a civil rights lawyer and
it's in the middle of that case and she
doesn't know
and so therefore this letter which isn't
a beautiful piece of literature one
might say but we know that this is when
history happened but she doesn't and I
think that's what's so wonderful about
this letter it's just an ordinary letter
Jade
dear mrs. joy oft I am very happy to
hear from you again thanks very much for
the contribution and the names of other
contributors we are having a difficult
time here but we are not discouraged the
increased pressure seems to strengthen
us for the next blow my first case was
heard in the circuit court february 22nd
i was found guilty and sentenced to 70
days in jail the appeal was made to the
state Supreme Court I was immediately
arrested again with the leaders of the
bus protests we have received very
generous contributions from over the
country although no specific appeal has
been made through the mail the
widespread publicity we are getting is
most disturbing to the local governing
group they resent outside interference
therefore I will have to take the matter
of direct appeal to the Montgomery
Improvement Association the Claudette
Colvin case is one of four filed with a
federal court at present I will write
again soon Sincerely Yours Rosa Elle
Parks
I love the formality of the Rosa l yeah
absolutely and the case you know it was
won in november 1956 so this is right in
the middle but I think one of the things
that I do like about it so much is it's
a reminder to all of us that the little
things also matter the fact that people
from outside the state are writing
letters and the governor doesn't like it
and it's so easy to think that big
history is only about the people in
charge but actually that for me that is
everybody can do something and I just
think that's you know I think it's a
great letter in a way it's interesting
isn't it see you back because there is a
in the entire book you get a real sense
of the different uses of letters you
know this is this is a private exchange
of course alluding to a really big
historical moment but there are public
letters there are you know huge letters
of significance that we know did change
history well that's right I mean
obviously my my definition as you'll see
of letters that change the world is very
broad but I'll explain I can explain why
every letters in there by the way if you
challenge me but but yes I mean
obviously there are public letters
there's Chairman Mao launching the
Cultural Revolution there are private
diplomatic letters the blank check
letter that we've all heard of in World
War one that launched world war one most
people have never actually read it and
it's in the book there are also many
private letters that were never meant to
be published and yet are fascinating to
read and there are letters by kings and
emperors but also by ordinary people
we've already heard some of those
tonight
so that's what I was trying to get was a
complete variety of voices and levels
and and you're right you know great
historical moments and private moments
for had great significance so the idea
of Rosa Parks and a Mitford girl being
in touch that really quite blew my mind
it's like that's so interesting that
they were you know they're not
everywhere they go let's focus on a real
specialist subject for you where so
we're going to turn to Lenin writing to
the Bolsheviks of Penzer well this this
is the real prepare to hear the real
voice of Lenin because you know for
and decades we were taught at school
that Stalin was the monster
but Lenin was essentially a decent sort
of almost could have patriarchal figure
in the Russian Revolution
well-intentioned and then Stalin turned
it and turned it cruel and nasty and
killed millions of people and I was
actually taught that at school pretty
much and probably many of you are and
you know nowadays more than ever at this
moment in our in our history it's key
that we know this stuff and so this
Nessa was only revealed after 1991 these
letters were all locked up and shown to
no one they were state secrets in the
Soviet Union only when the Soviet Union
fell were these red and now you can see
the real Lenin the Lenin who said a
revolution without firing squads is
meaningless and here you see that in
action and Jack will you read the letter
and by the way ladies and gentlemen
listen out for the last line that tells
you all you need to know comrades the
insurrection of five Kulik districts
should be pitilessly suppress the
interests of the whole revolution
require this because the last decisive
battle with the kulaks is now underway
everywhere an example must be
demonstrated number one hang and make
sure that the hanging takes place in
full view of people no fewer than 100
known cool acts rich men
bloodsuckers number to publish their
names three seize all their grain from
them and four designate hostages in
accordance with yesterday's telegram do
it in such a fashion that for hundreds
of kilometers around that people might
see tremble no shout they are strangling
and will strangle to death the blood
sucking cool acts
Telegraph receipt and implementation use
Lenin find some truly hard people
it's a real measure of precision in
ruthlessness they're astonishing
yeah and he was he was install and also
did that they used to number everything
and I'm number their orders and you know
when when he was when he people was as I
said people always said that Stalin was
a terrible distortion of Lenin but when
he was first introduced to Stalin and
someone said Stalin's you know Stalin's
killed people Stalin's done all these
terrible things he said he said let's
let's use him that's exactly the type
I'm looking for and so you can see the
real Lenin Lenin Trotsky star and they
were all very much the same they
believed in terror and they believed in
mass killing as a way to change society
and these letters which this is just one
all demonstrate just how absolutely
terrifying Lee fanatically ruthless they
were but also there's a contrast in the
book with a letter of Stalin's daughter
that's right I mean they also led normal
lives at the same time you know one of
the letters which I found actually is a
letter from Stalin's daughter aged nine
stet Lana in which what if you were
Stalin's daughter aged nine what would
you do to to play she pretends to be the
dictator of Russia and so and she signs
her orders I'm spent on a Stalin first
secretary of the Communist Party the
boss actually and she writes it to
starlet Comrade Stalin Molotov barrier
and one of them which I think I've got
in the book says I hereby order that all
homework in the Soviet Union should be
abolished for a year and and Stalin and
all the Politburo signed the letter and
stuck it on their fridge in their
apartment in the Kremlin I think the
other thing that's so interesting about
that letter and what you say see a bag
about what you discovered and what we
were taught about Lenin and Stalin oh
the goodie and the body essentially is
that you know it's a shabby old cliche
the idea that history is always written
by the victors but there is a something
more insidious about it which is history
is also written with an agenda the story
that people want to tell and I think
this letter is a really good example of
that that the decision is made that
Lenin is the paternalistic one he's the
good one really and he did things
reluctantly and his own words condemn
him and that is actually the
architecture of war and terror is the
same whether it's in the 12th century
the 4th century the 21st century
it's the same architecture shame people
name them treat people as an example and
it and that's why that letter I think is
so so chilling me ok let's talk about
the letter that Barbra wrote to his son
who Mayan
which has some real lessons for us today
- it's a beautiful letter and it was
written in 1529 and it's a letter of
tolerance and it's very much you know
father to a son and Bob or himself who
was born in 1483 he was a prince
descended from a great line but his his
family had fallen from its glory if you
like and almost single-handedly he
restored the glory and he restored they
took over the conquest of India and he
founded his own dynasty the moguls and
here he's writing when he's about 45 and
it's only just shortly before his death
but he is giving this beautiful advice
to the boy that will come after him as
summer come after him
and as you say we should be listening to
this now and kwame's gonna read it for
us oh my son the realm of Hindustan is
full of diverse Creed's praise be to God
the righteous the glorious the highest
that he had granted unto thee the Empire
of it it is but proper that you with
heart cleansed of all religious bigotry
should dispense justice according to the
tenants of each community and in
particular refrain from the sacrifice of
cow for that way lies the conquest of
the hearts of the people of Hindustan
and the subjects of the realm well
through royal favor be devoted to thee
and the temples and abodes of worship of
every community under imperial sway
should not be damaged
dispense justice so that the sovereign
may be happy with the subjects and
likewise the subjects with their
sovereign the progress of Islam is
better by the sword of kindness not by
the sword of oppression ignore the
disputations of Shearson and the and
Sonny's for therein is the weakness of
Islam and bring together the subjects
with different beliefs in the matter of
the four elements so that the body
politic may be immune from the various
ailments and on us is but the duty to
advise
just hearing that again having read it
in the book see bag I mean it couldn't
be more prescient given that we've got
two nuclear powers in South Asia eyeing
themselves up you know edging towards
the brink and pulling pulling themselves
back I mean it couldn't be a greater
lesson for tolerance and and and being
calm in the face of difficulty well Bob
o is one of the most extraordinary
characters and lovable characters in
history I mean he wrote a memoir which
is really the kind of first kind of
modern memoir has written in in the
1520's and he writes about his love
affairs with boys his love affairs with
girls a few battles chopping off a few
heads many parties a lot of drinking he
writes up he write he's a poet and and
he found he's a great great nephew of
Tana Tamil a in the great Conqueror he
fails to win Sam Samarkand and instead
he's left to take Kabul and Afghanistan
which he doesn't want and then just by
luck he sees a chance and he invades
India and he founds the Mughal dynasty
and he he gets the absolute heart of
ruling India which is to tolerate every
every you know that the shears the
Sunnis and the hint and the Hindus which
of course is the great lesson which the
present Government of India could learn
the British the British also could have
learned lessons from all these things
that all the rulers of that part of the
world could still learn from this it's a
wonderful letter of tolerance I wonder
how you reflect on on it having just
read it again I I think one thinks about
how prescient it is to today you know we
just have to look at the news right and
see and see as we've said that these two
countries are at the brink of war and
it's also there's something beautiful
about about reading letters of many
centuries ago and knowing that that we
still think at the same that we still
believe in the same things that
quintessentially our hearts seek peace
and love and tolerance that was very
beautiful to read that and
and muse on that I suppose also the the
the wisdom of a father passing something
on to his son in the hope that he'll
absorb it and continue in that vein but
as well is yes and it's also the beauty
of the way that he addresses the son oh
my son and immediately you're kind of
melting around that audio and there a
book you know other letters in the book
that are being written you know
obviously in Tudor England at exactly
the same date with a very different sort
of tenor so you believe for me reading
that that that father loved that son
this is not just an official letter
it isn't just I don't want my dynasty to
go down the tubes you know because I'm
about to die you've just believed that
there's love there as well and that
there's a purpose to what he was doing
so and and I didn't know very anything
about him really at all so I'm you know
grateful to this book because I thought
no he sounded he's more interested in
Tudors we've had enough of the Tudors
we'll stay with the family theme but
again against a much bigger backdrop
Vilma Grunewald to her husband Kurt I
think this is the most heartbreaking
letter in the book and I can never
really hear it every time I hear it it's
it's it breaks my heart again this is
one of the very few letters that were
actually smuggled out of the death camps
not the labor camps run by the Nazis in
World War two during the Holocaust but
the actual death camps and this letter
is also extraordinary because it
contains a Sophie's Choice decision
which is which is unthinkable and
unspeakable to all of us
the Grunwald family a doctor his wife
and his two children one of whom was
mildly handicapped arrived at Auschwitz
in in 1944 and when they went to the
selection process on the railway on the
railway station at Auschwitz they faced
the the appalling judgement of Josef
Mengele the angel of death the doctor
who made the selections and as he went
down as he selected them there was left
those to the left will die and be gassed
immediately those to the right will
survive and when he came to this family
he said to the Father to the right he's
a doctor and he's a healthy man he'll
survive he said to the mother to the
right you'll survive he said to the
other son the healthy son to the right
but he said to the handicapped son to
the left and the mother in that split
second made an unbearable decision but a
marvelous decision she said I'll go with
him even though she'd been chosen to
live and so she went to the left and
when they were waiting they realized by
talking to other people and some of the
kind of guards that they were going to
be murdered immediately and they didn't
know how and so she got a bit of paper
and she wrote this letter and and you
know she gave it to a guard and the
chances of this been given to anybody to
reaching her husband were very low but
amazingly the letter was given to her
husband Kurt in the in the labor camp he
survived the war and he later gave this
to one of the Holocaust the Holocaust
Museum in in in the States I think and
you'll judge for yourself what she said
Tamsin's gonna read it to you
you my only one dearest in isolation we
are waiting for darkness we considered
the possibility of hiding but decided
not to do it since we felt it would be
hopeless the famous trucks are already
here
and we are waiting for it to begin I am
completely calm you my only and dearest
one do not blame yourself for what
happened it was our destiny we did what
we could stay healthy and remember my
words that time will heal if not
completely then at least partially take
care of the little golden boy and don't
spoil him too much with your love both
of you stay healthy my dear ones I will
be thinking of you and Misha have a
fabulous life we must board the trucks
into eternity bill No
[Applause]
slightly speechless by your reading rad
dude if you ran yeah I'd like you just
to reflect on on you having to prepare
for it and just read yeah I'd like it
you like now - oh yeah if that would be
okay
only because I can't answer well a
director that I worked with many years
ago gave me a very sound piece of advice
and he said that he felt that an actor
should decide whether the character
therapy they're playing is seeking to
express emotion or deal with emotion
and he said that most actors do a lot of
expressing and the interesting ones are
dealing with him
and so what strikes me in this letter is
that it's a woman who is so beautifully
and compassionately dealing with her own
devastation and giving so much life you
know beyond that and we are I think we
have fallen into the rather dangerous
position of expressing ourselves rather
than loving others by asking them to
have a fabulous life we're choosing to
have a fabulous life the generosity of
that last time is wonderful
yeah thank you so much
[Music]
let's see beg you you split up this book
into it somatically rather than
chronologically and and this next letter
appears in the in the creativity section
this is a letter that Michelangelo wrote
to Giovanni the pistoi and Kate I think
you're going to introduce well actually
I mean see bag nose double well I think
we put this one here obviously after
that beautiful last letter but it's
quite a good reminder of how some of the
things that give us such pleasure is so
beautiful in this case the Sistine
Chapel and everybody knows the story of
Michelangelo being asked to do that and
building all the structures around it
and it was Genesis and the story of
humankind and God's gift to the world
and how beautiful that is and whether
you see it in a picture or we've stood
underneath it it is one of those things
that makes your heart sing and then you
read this letter and you remember the
real artist and what he suffered to make
this piece of beauty that has long
outlasted him and will hopefully outlast
us all and the thing about Michelangelo
apart from obviously being a great
painter and a sculptor he was a
beautiful wordsmith and he often sent
his poems as letters which of course we
all want that friend who sends these
beautiful letter stirrers in in poetry
form and this of course you know this
was letter was written in 1509 but the
chapel's ceiling was not finished until
1512 and it really he was writing this
in the middle of it so it just makes you
think of what people do to give us all
pleasure and kwame you're gonna read the
letter for us I've already grown a
greater from this torture swollen up
here like a cat from Lombardi or
anywhere else where the stagnant waters
poison my stomach squashed under the my
chin my beards pointing at heaven my
brains crushed in a casket my breasts
twist like a harpy my brush above me all
the time tribbles the pain so my face
makes a fine floor for droppings
my haunches are grinding into my guts my
poor are strains to work as a
counterweight every gesture I make is
blind and aimless my skin hangs loose
below me my spines are knotted from
folding over itself I'm bent taut like a
Syrian bow and because I'm like this my
thoughts are crazy
perfidious tripe anyone shoots badly
through a crooked blowpipe my painting
is dead defend it for me Giovanni
protects my honor I'm not in the right
place I am NOT a painter
I love the resistance to creativity in
that and it's just so witty I mean he
was just I mean as Kate said I mean he
was one of these people who could do
everything you know he could he could go
down to the mines and cut out a block of
marble and and and work out and know how
to transport it and know how to choose
it he could he obviously he was a
sculptor he didn't think of himself as a
painter at all but of course I mean you
know look look at the Sistine Chapel he
was he was also against Kate said a
great poet you know he was more than his
poetry is amazing his love poetry you
know often to young young boys but also
to female friends is so beautiful and so
amazing and he published it I mean he I
mean he he was proud of his poetry and
this was an early achievement an
incredibly long life and he went on to
run the building of some Peters and and
and then of course this is you know he
had he's kind of he was an impossible
person to work with and he had this kind
of completely vicious relationship with
the Pope pope julius ii who commissioned
this so anyway all of it you can get the
sort of grit and his personality and
that letter which you read so
beautifully let's move on to another
parent-child letter this is a maria
teresa - Marie Antoinette know we've
missed that one oh it's our favorite
letter okay okay so the next one
apologies Sarah Bernhardt - mrs. Patrick
Campbell Kate tell us about this one
well I mean I think probably everybody
knows Sarah Bernhardt you know this this
incredible great woman who was an
actress a thinker free spirit a dancer
she was the daughter of a Parisian
Jewish what was here she was a courtesan
really I think we're using word
courtesan and and no I think that's fair
enough and an unknown client were using
that word as well so she didn't really
know about it but she was completely
self-made and she was just one of those
women that was going to just do stuff
regardless and of course she became
legendary and all over France in but
wherever you go every single hotel that
is older than a hundred years says Sarah
Bernhardt slept here you think she must
have spent her entire life asleep
frankly but this letter you know mrs.
Patrick Campbell was also a very famous
actress known as mrs. Pat and she lived
life to the fall but also things
sometimes went wrong and you will
understand why I'm giving you the detail
of this before Tamsin
reads from the letter and this letter
was sent in 1915 and one of the things
that she was known for was that whatever
happened she just got up the show must
go on so she fell during a performance
of of lattis Kerr in Rio de Janeiro's
she fell 15 feet from a balcony quite
early in her career and she broke her
knee and it never really mended properly
and she was in agony for most of the
rest of her life
and here a long time after the accident
she's 70 years old now she is writing to
her friend mrs. Pat in 1915 just to say
that she has decided to sort her knee
out Tamsin
dr. will cut off my leg next Monday and
very happy kisses all my heart sarah
bernhardt
I don't think that requires any
commentary what Maria Theresa - Marie
Antoinette a mother writes to her
daughter Kate yes well this is I mean if
ever you want to say to a teenage girl
listen to your mother
this letter is it I mean it really is so
Mary Theresa she's in her late 50s at
this moment it's 1775 and she is one of
those real grand Doughty Empress's of
France and she has worked all of her
life to build this structure of being
royal and the royal family and all of
this thing and she is pulled off this
incredible coup which is that she has
essentially married her daughter Marie
Antoinette off to a rather aging well
the ermine he's dull he's boring louis
xvi
and he's you know he's supposed to be
this is obviously a great catch though
she's now married into the world family
but it is entirely clear that this 19
year old ain't so keen on her husband
and obviously there's been many letters
before this particular one that we're
going to hear where she's clearly saying
look just just calm down love calm down
listen to your mother and then finally
she she writes a letter which is half in
sorrow and half an anger and of course
the thing is again the brilliance of
these letters is with hindsight we know
that she is right to talk about the
misfortune that might fall upon her
daughter and she's giving her advice
because she loves her and she will as
she asks in the letter not lived to see
the French Revolution and she will not
live to see her daughter beheaded and I
think that is for a slightly longer
letter back to Tamsin
madam my dear daughter I cannot hide
from you that a letter you sent to
minister Rosenberg upset me most
dreadfully what style what frivolity
where is the good and generous heart of
the Archduchess Antoinette
I see only intrigue vulgar spite delight
in mockery and persecution an intrigue
which would do very well for a pompadour
or a de berry but never for a queen a
great princess still less a princess
kindly and good of the house of Lorraine
and Austria all the winter long I have
trembled at the thought of your too easy
success and the flutter is surrounding
you while you have thrown yourself into
a life of pleasure and preposterous
display this chasing from pleasure to
pleasure without the king and knowing
that he takes no joy in it and only goes
with you or lets you do what you want
how to shear goods Nature has made me
right before to express my fears I see
now from this letter that these were all
too well justified your luck can all too
easily change and by your own fault you
may well find yourself plunged into
deepest misery that is the result of
your terrible dissipation
which prevents your being Sidious about
anything serious what have you read and
after that you dare to opine on the
greatest states matters on the choice of
ministers what does the a bay do and
mercy you dislike them because instead
of behaving like low flatterers they
want you to be happy and do not take
advantage of your weaknesses one day you
will recognize the truth of this but
then it will be too late I hope I shall
not survive until misfortune overtakes
you and I pray to God to end my days
quickly since I am no longer of any use
to you and I could not bear to lose my
dear child or see her unhappy whom I
shall love tenderly until I die
[Music]
don't make me talk I'm not going to I've
learned my lesson it's extraordinary
isn't it that you learn so much about
the person who's written the letter and
to whom it's being sent yeah yeah and I
think with those letters there are there
are quite a few obviously parent to
child letters in the book but for me one
of the things about that letter is not
just the hindsight that we know she's
right regardless of how the master
nations have got her there but we know
what's coming but I think it's also the
cry of older overlooked women everywhere
that she has been the Empress she has
been that person in charge and she is
aging and getting older and she's kind
of no longer got the stomach for this
she loves her daughter and she wants her
daughter to pull herself together but
she knows that her power is gone and
actually that's why I find that letter
so moving it's the it's it's the cry of
all parents don't leave me don't leave
me I mean by that stage 75 she ruled for
35 years so and she'd been you know
Empress of Austria the greatest Anna
Habsburg so you know the grandest family
in Europe and she'd managed to marry her
daughter to the king of France who was
extremely dull bored a boring mediocre
man who was really happiest not with his
beautiful young wife but with his
collection of clocks and she loved to
watch and and and so she writes this
letter in absolute despair but also
there's a great sort of I mean you can
hear in that the house of Austria is the
House of Habsburg and you know and she's
talking about the dew berries and the
pompadours and those are the mistresses
of the old king of France the very the
very disreputable the kardashians of
their day but she's denouncing that
let's move on to a love letter C bagnat
sir here you talk about free DeCarlo
writing to Diego Frida Kahlo
I mean her letters are as colorful
exotic brave and sensuous as her
paintings and in a way that they come
from the same place and they're one of
examples in the book of artists like
Michelangelo like Mozart who write these
these letters that show
that they were also incredibly
articulate in words as well
she had an incredibly tragic life she
was she was in some ways she symbolized
the the the racial variety of Mexico she
was she was part American Indian she was
part Jewish and German to his part
Spanish as a young girl she wanted to be
an artist but she had suffered from
polio then she endured this nightmarish
accident in a bus which those of you
who've seen the movie with Salma Hayek
or remember when a steel girder went
right through her uterus and she
survived this crippled always in agony
always wearing braces and special
supports and undergoing nightmarish
treatments and yet she survived us to
become an incredible liberated woman who
had affairs with Trotsky with Josephine
Baker and married Diego Rivera the great
artist and she the two of them became
the artistic personification of Mexico
and still are and this is is just one of
her letters and Jade's going to read it
for us Diego nothing compares to your
hands nothing like the green gold of
your eyes my body is filled with you for
days and days you are the mirror of the
night
the violent flash of lightning the
dampness of the earth the hollow of your
armpits is my shelter my fingers touch
your blood all my joy is to feel life
spring from your flower fountain that
mine keeps to fill all the paths of my
nerves which are yours
I think when the take-home from this
evening is going to be flower fountain I
think isn't it
si bag let's talk about Catherine the
Great and Prince Potemkin these are
wonderful letters well well this is this
is this is the best way to end a quarrel
and Catherine and Potemkin were really
one of the probably the most successful
political partnership in all of history
and we forget about Napoleon and
Josephine or Ava Peron and and Perron
Antony and Cleopatra Potemkin and
Catherine were equals they were
incredible passionate love affair but
they also succeeded amazingly well
politically and they were very different
he was Russian undisciplined oftentimes
when she was talking to ambassadors in
it the French ambassador in a formal
Imperial audience the door were at one
door at the end of the room would open
and Potemkin would walk through the room
just in a pair of Turkish pantaloons
chewing on an apple and wearing a
bandana like a rock star and just walk
through he wouldn't say anything to he
just walk out and walk out the other
door and the Empress had to continue as
if nothing had happened while she was
very oddly very Germanic would wake up
at 6:00 in the morning
cook her own coffee and get to work so
but the two thing one thing they had in
common was talent they were both
incredibly brilliant intellectuals
brilliant politicians but their
relationship was very very
confrontational he wanted to be the
Prime Minister bizarre almost she was
bizarre and they had to work it out so
in the end they secretly married and
they arranged an amazing sort of form of
marriage whereby they would rule the
country together be married and yet each
have young lovers which you know some
might say it's a very civilized way to
organize your life country and it's a
big country it's a big country so
now this this letter really captures
their one one side of their relationship
and the personal side and and we're
going to start off with Prince Potemkin
x' letter to Catherine which is going to
be read by Kwame let me my love say this
which will I hope end our argument don't
be surprised that I'm disturbed by our
love not only have you showered me with
good deeds you have placed me in your
heart I want to be there alone and above
everyone else because no one has ever
loved you so much and I have been made
by your hands that you should be happy
and being good to me
that you should find rest from the great
labors arising from your high station in
thinking about my comfort she receives
she receives this letter from Prince
Potemkin now you have to imagine their
each separate ends of the Winter Palace
and you know how long the Winter Palace
is so imagine it's like an email except
actually each reply would be carried by
servants running the length of the
Winter Palace so between each line
you've got a man you've got to hear the
pitter-patter of a feet as a as a
servant runs the whole length of winter
pants and hands the letter to the to the
other one and this amazing couple and
now Tamsin is going to read the reply so
if you both read the letter in its full
panoply let me my love say this I allow
it which will I hope end our argument
the sooner the better
don't be surprising I'm disturbed by
don't be disturbed not only have you
showered me with good deeds you have
placed me in your heart I want to be
there alone and above everyone else you
are there firmly and strongly and will
remain there because no one has ever
loved you
I see it and believe it and I have been
made by your hands happy to do so
but that you should be happy and being
good to me it will be my greatest
pleasure that you should find rest from
the great labors arising from your high
station in thinking of my comfort of
course give rest to our thoughts and let
our feelings act freely they are most
tender and will find the best way end of
quarrel
[Music]
wonderful thank you so much we are going
to press on let's see back introduce for
us letters between so again it says it
yes time it's not what I've got on my
snow nobody told me
okay so these are letters between Simon
Bolivar Manuela scions and James thorn I
think it is yeah you're welcome to know
I mean this is this is again what
happens when you write a letter to your
lover telling them it's over and they
write back and say no it isn't and this
involves two of the great characters of
history that are less well-known in
England and that's right it's why it's
one of the fun things is putting these
for the characters in this in this
anthology
I mean Bolivar is the genius of the
storm is how he described himself
modestly and he was the man who
liberated three-quarters of South
America I think eight countries
including Bolivia which has causes named
after him but Venezuela Colombia and he
ended up as president of a country that
included Colombia Venezuela Bolivia
Ecuador and Peru
so quite a man and this was before he
was before he was about forty he
deliberated these countries he was also
a great lover and he said his best ideas
came to him when he was dancing at a
ball and with a beautiful girl and when
he met Manuela science he'd really met
his match she was much younger than him
and she was already married to an
Englishman called James thorn but they
fell passionately in love but he had to
live the life of a warlord and he wasn't
thought sure and the relationship could
last and beside she was married so let
us begin with Jack I'm writing to Jade
who is Manuela who's also going to join
him on the stage
I want to answer most beautiful Manuela
your demands of love which are entirely
reasonable but I have to be candid with
you who have given me so much of
yourself it's time you knew that long
ago I loved the woman as only the young
can love out of respect I never talked
about it
and I'm I'm pondering these things and I
want to give you time to do the same
because your words lure me because I
know that this may well be my moment to
love you and for us to love one another
I need time to to get used to this for
for a military life is neither easy to
endure nor easy to leave behind I I have
fooled death so many times now that
death dogs might every step but allow me
to be sure of myself of you I I cannot
lie I never lie my passion for you is
wild and you know it
just give me time
well Manuela as you might have guessed
is not the sort of person who's gonna
take no for an answer
so she was incredibly formidable
character who liked to dress up I like
to ride into battle dressed as a colonel
and who was a complete free spirit and
but she was still married to her
Englishman mr. thorn so what she does is
she's not gonna be sent back to mr.
thorn
she writes a letter to mr. thorn which
she copies to Simone Bolivar and and
this is the letter which um Jade is
going to read no no no hambre a thousand
times no sir you are an excellent person
indeed one of a kind that I will never
Dena me I only regret that you are not a
better man so that my leaving you would
honor
Bolivar more I know very well that I can
never be joined to him in what you call
Honor do you think I am any less
honourable because he is my lover not my
husband
ah I do not live by social conventions
men construct to torment us so leave me
be My dear Englishman we will marry
again in heaven but not on this earth on
earth you are a boring man
up there in the celestial Heights
everything will be so English because a
life of monotony was invented for you
people who make love without pleasure
conversation without grace who walked
slowly greet solemnly move heavily joke
without laughing but enough of my
cheekiness with all the sobriety truth
and clarity of an English woman I say
now I will never return for you you are
a Protestant and I a pagan that should
be obstacle enough but I am also in love
with another man and that is the greater
stronger reason you see how precise my
mind can be your invariable friend
Manuela
but you are a boring man she just gives
us women so much strength I wonder if we
can just have a real change of mood and
tone now and Kate if you would introduce
the letter that Alan Turing wrote to
Norman ravage yes and I mean I think for
me this was one of the most
heartbreaking letters in the entire
collection and it was written in 1952
when homosexuality was still illegal in
the UK and at this moment Turing was
living in Manchester and he was having
an affair with a young man and the most
extraordinary sequence of bad luck
really happened in that this young man
was burgled and the police came and in
the course of just being a normal
citizen being looked after by the police
it came out that they were lovers
and as a result Turing was arrested and
you just imagine how they had been
hiding all of these things for so long
and then it was something so other that
actually caught them if you like and he
was you know try it was was arrested for
gross indecency and he avoided a prison
sentence by agreeing to undergo a
chemical treatment which is quite
similar to chemical castration and now
looking back in his biographers safe
this was the beginning of the end for
him kind of finished him off and as you
will know he committed suicide a couple
of years later and so he didn't live to
see a homosexuality being decriminalized
in the UK in 1967 and he also didn't of
course live to see Turing's law in 2007
which finally pardoned all of those
people who were so wronged by the
country that should have been grateful
to them so jack is gonna read this
really wonderful letter which just
reminds us actually in these difficult
times how some things are better than
they were
My dear Norman I've now got myself into
the kind of trouble that I've always
considered to be quite a possibility for
me though I have usually rated it at
about 10 to 1 against I shall shortly be
pleading guilty to a charge of sexual
offences with a young man the story of
how it all came to be found out as a
long and fascinating one which I shall
have to make into a short story one day
but haven't the time to tell you now no
doubt I shall emerge from it all a
different man but quite who I've not
found out I'm afraid that the following
syllogism may be used by some in the
future cheering believes machines think
Turing lies with men
therefore machines do not think using
distress our
see bag where there are other letters
that he had written and you chose this
one in particular this is the this is
the one that really displays the sort of
sheer agony he was going through and you
know when he talked about the machine
you know he was really this is the man
who'd kind of really been those of you
there's been a movie on it recently as
you know as you probably many of you
have seen but you know he'd been
absolutely brilliant at the it codifying
the codification jingle war he'd been it
works on breaking the Enigma code at
Bletchley Park and he'd had the first
concept of how a computer would work and
that's what the machine is talking about
there yeah artificially intelligent he'd
invented or these units of this man is a
towering genius and he's been brought
down by this incredible injustice and
cruelty and the punishment they devised
I mean it reminds me a little bit of
with another letter that's also near
which is the Oscar Wilde letters the
letters that brought Oscar Wilde to his
downfall and you know it's just a
heartbreaking thing that there's a very
unjust law against homosexuality
destroyed this man and this sentence of
art of castration by chemical treatment
it was just appalling you know beyond
medieval torture really and it just it
literally destroyed him as a man so
heartbreaking heartbreaking that erm and
I think one of the things that is so
moving about that for me reading it is
that we there are lots of letters in the
book and we've heard some of them this
evening where you are aware that history
is being made you know Lenin is saying
hang them all published their name so we
know that this is history but there's
also we know that the way that history
works is often you know that the poem
for the want of a nail and the fact that
he would have been hiding all of his
life but he was found out because a
burglary happened actually nothing to do
with him really and I think that that's
the thing that is always worth
remembering these letters that it's the
way the different way that history is
made and it's just those tear
all terrible moments of bad luck when
the light that tiny moment of light and
as a stumble and that was actually the
end of him and it but also the fact that
we know that if he'd been alive today he
would be the most kind of honored man in
our society he would be a member of the
order of merit he would be in the you
know he would have been knighted and yet
just just the fact that he was born at
that time
sentenced him to this great injustice
yeah but I think it's also worth I mean
that is one of the things that you know
we all sit here in the context of
everything that goes on around us and
what we think and the things we read and
all the rest read but sometimes it is
good to remember that this was awful and
the Lord did change and it's not that
law here now it is in other countries
but it's not here and I think that's one
of the things that I think is so great
about the pattern in the book that you
can see that things do get better
in some ways even if they also get worse
than others and I think that's quite
important that this book gives a bit of
hope we're almost approaching the end of
the evening we've got one more letter
but we're going to open up the floor to
questions
if there are any happily waving
excellent thank you so my question is to
Simon about the the sort of criteria
that you had for choosing each letter
and whether you also considered the
fictional you opened with a quote from
Goethe and as far as I'm aware the
surahs of Young Werther did change the
world made him a literary star he work
was carried by Napoleon during his
campaign and it is the first recorded
instances of copycat suicides that were
generated from that book and also about
if you could comment a bit more about
Oscar Wilde and perhaps the greatest
letter ever written the 50,000 word De
Profundis
thank you yeah
a good question I mean De Profundis I
absolutely love De Profundis but it was
too long there's so much bit there's so
much of it but there are actually bits
quoted in here because there are a few
bits of that that I love so much that
I've put in I've put in here because the
great thing about this collection of
letters is I could put what I like to
knit which is a great thing and I love
this there's a moment in De Profundis
when Oscar Wilde comes out and everyone
is spitting at him and and booing him
and he's been destroyed he's fallen from
the heights and as he walks through the
crowd everyone is just sneering at him
and his face is covered and spit and he
sees his friend Robbie Ross standing in
front of him and Robbie Ross takes his
hat off and boughs to him and Oscar
Wilde says in day profundus the men have
gone to heaven for lesser things he's so
grateful so it's such a touching moment
but but there are no fit there were no
fictional letters in here obviously is
it but but but there are many letters by
artists by creative people by novelist
there's a letter from Paul Zak there's a
letter from Mozart my criteria was
letters that change the world in some
way that only I can define and I mean
for example you know Frida Kahlo is in
there because I love Frida Carlo but
also because she really defined for the
first time the arc the woman as artists
and that is that is a way that that is a
way that changed the way she changed the
world and I asked Nina is in here and in
her letters with Henry Miller they're
wonderful love letters but she defined
how women can write about love and
sensuality in a way that no one had
before so actually even even even the
letters that seemed kind of barking that
they're in here are in here for a reason
I'm sure you could produce several books
when you chose choose completely
different letters and it would be as
enjoyable well we had to throw out you
know we had to throw out a lot of
letters that we couldn't put in here
because we we had to be like I mean I
mean I found so many and the criterias
just letters that I'd like to read
really that I wanted to read myself so
that's that's right isn't it
of course did you have a microphone go
ahead yes thank you
well we're talking about letters that
change the world but I think that if we
don't write the world there's also going
to change in another way so I am for the
preservation of handwriting all of us
collectively and sometimes I'm 38 and
sometimes you blame into the new
generation that they are not writing but
it is us who stopped doing it to show
them the way so I wonder and this is my
question how are you preserving
handwriting and what you recommend us to
keep this going
thank you that's that's a great question
and one of the themes of the book is
like let's write letters more you know
this is like a celebration of
letter-writing I mean a historian
historic - there were a 500 year period
when people wrote I mean care from the
great described herself as a graphic
maniac she would write all night every
night and I'm too many different sorts
of letters many too many different
people and the telephone and then he
internet and texting of course have
destroyed it one of the interesting
things is that the late the latest the
fact that like emails and so on are so
insecure now have started to change that
and I think letter-writing will come
back just as the book has come back
people said the book was going to be
extinct but actually we love holders
it's actually coming back and books are
selling more than they were a few years
ago and I'm you know talking to people I
talk to people in them in government in
the intelligence services they all now
much prefer writing letters with an old
pen because you know the security
services of all of the CIA and and so on
are all harvesting our emails to read
them and they're not secure anymore when
I speak to someone in the Kremlin they
said I said well does President Putin
use and they said well he used to use he
used to use black braid and then he used
whatsapp and then he used Telegraph and
when they when they owned as a telegraph
wouldn't give him the codes he's gone
back to writing on paper with a
Montblanc pen
and I said well I said why and he said
like look we're the Russians you know
where the people who really know about
Internet insecurity and so if we're
using more blog pens now so should all
of you you've all read these letters so
beautifully do any of you hand write
letters you know I haven't written edges
but I received a beautiful letter maybe
a few months ago the teacher that made
the difference to my life you know that
we all have that of that battle that one
and and she came to see a show of mine
and and I was like a child in the lobby
when when I met her and then I didn't
hear anything for like days afterwards I
wasn't really nervous as I had she hated
it and then she wrote me this four-page
letter and and III I felt like I could I
could have wept there was and it's it's
really special it's gonna stay with me
all the days of my life I thought I do
remember the day at High School where I
it was we had social education up in
Scotland I can't even remember what that
is
but I remember being so bored in that
class continually that one day I decided
to change the slant of my handwriting to
the other side and it's literally been
that way since that day because I was
sat not listening and when did you write
you are a boring
I got a letter says very quickly I got a
letter and I don't know how it got to me
sent from a woman who's that who was a
nurse working in a a camp on the Burmese
Thai border I don't know how she got the
Sesame's handwritten letter to say that
she was there she'd been there for a
long time she had her young son with her
and the and her son had night terrors
and the only thing that would calm him
down was watching VHS tapes of a show I
did on telephone called black books I'm
not gonna take any credit for that
because you know it was a great show
because of those two guys but the fact
that she wanted to tell me and I and
wrote this long beautiful letter and got
it to me and you know that's the
treasure that's success that's nice I
think you've got the microphone to say
yes I did
I attempted to say that was my question
but if she wanted to take you to the
very beginning of discussion when one of
you ladies I don't remember which one
I'm sorry mentioned that lets us seem to
be coming back to fashion
apart from KGB and all that do we have
any evidence of that I mean one of the
bizarre things about these matters is
some of these letters were written to be
to be published I mean especially 18th
century people wrote letters in order to
be copied I mean but then there's a
whole lot of other letters in here which
were written in such secrecy it would
have like been unthinkable that these
letters would I mean that like the
letter we heard from Mary Ann Toinette
you know the Empress of Austria to the
Queen of France that is a letter between
heads of state that was never meant to
have been to been read all seen by
anybody and yet we're seeing it and of
course there lots of erotic letters in
the book that of course no one was meant
to see and yet they were capped
so let us our secret thing as well as a
public thing and that's one of the joys
of letters let's have one more question
hi were there any letters that were
never sent and you think if they had
been sent would have changed the world
well yeah there's one there's one letter
in the book that wasn't saying that is
in the book and that's the letter that
on just in June 1944 just as just before
d-day on the day of d-day General Dwight
Eisenhower who was the Supreme
commander-in-chief of d-day wrote two
letters and the first letter was to say
we have successfully landed in Normandy
you know and congratulations to all the
forces of the American British armies we
have begun the liberation of Europe and
the other letter he wrote was the letter
that said I'm afraid there's been a
major debacle we have failed to land on
the beaches of Normandy we've been we've
been totally defeated and and the
disaster is totally my fault and I take
full responsibility for it so he wrote
both these letters by hand and and he
put them on his desk and he went out to
order he checked the weather and then he
ordered d-day to begin so he never sent
the second letter and lettin key letters
not being received that though the
marriage you know between Henry of
Navarre and Margaux Marguerite and it
was supposed to bring peace to France
and you know Wars of Religion in
sixteenth-century and the Pope had sent
a letter that had to our special
permission for these the Catholic and
the Protestants to be married and there
is a lot of evidence that catherine de'
me she shut all the gates so that the
Pope's letter could not be received and
the Pope's letter said they cannot marry
but by the time the letters you know it
was clear that she it was another plot
as it were they have been married and
those were letters as well the idea that
they're out there but they never got to
where they were supposed to get I mean
that's just fascinating it's matched a
Finnish honor that's sort of definite
though because my name is Simon C bag
there's a famous plastic surgeon in
London called
does he cook Joseph multi called dr. C
bag and I regularly receive letters that
amount that I meant for him
at my house obviously and because and
because the two names are next door to
each other
they're always from people that I know
really well and I should just say I
haven't put any of those letters in the
book but you should read them thank you
all very much for your questions we have
one final letter that we are going to
hear this evening and it's a letter
written by Leonard Cohen to Mary Ann it
'ln and a C bag you're going to
introduce that well I mean I think the
greatest art and letter writing is to
know how to say goodbye and you all know
who Leonard Cohen was he was the great
singer songwriter poet who wrote great
songs like Suzanne and Sisters of Mercy
and Matt I'm so long Mary Ann and Mary
Ann in those songs was his love affair
that he had on the island of Hydra in
Greece in the 60s with a beautiful
Norwegian girl called Mary Ann ebloom
and jump ahead many many years he's in
his 80s it's 2016 she's she's the same
age and she finds out that she has
leukemia and she's dying in a hospital
in Oslo and she calls in her best friend
who later wrote to me and told me the
story in detail she called her best
friend she said I'm dying
can you let Leonard know and they hadn't
been in contact for over 40 years
at all but they knew that each that they
were the greatest love of their lives
and so this guy who was her best friend
went to his email got her found she gave
him the Leonard's email she sent a
mini-me sent her a minute
email and he said like you know
Ariana's here with Mia she's dying and I
hope this reaches you in time because
I'm not sure she's going to last the
night and they went to and he went the
heath had a sleepless night in the
hospital and it dawn and checked his
email and this this was the letter that
he found from then a cone which Kwame is
going to read to close the proceedings
tonight
dearest Marianne I'm just a little
behind you close enough to take your
hand this whole body has given up as
yours has to and the eviction notices on
its way any day now I've never forgotten
your love and your beauty but you know
that I don't have to say more safe
travel was our friend see you down the
road
endless love and gratitude
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much just leaves me to say
thank you to Jade Anika Jack Loudon
Tamsin Greig Kwame way Armour Simon C
vague Montefiore and Kate Moss and of
course too intelligent squared for
putting on a fabulous event thank you so
much everyone for coming
you